und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
und marietta slomka
guten abend bei der bund länder runde
zur corona lage heute ließen sich vor
allem zwei ziele ausmachen erstens
anreize fürs boostern zu setzen wer
dreifach geimpft ist kann auch mal
schnell auf eine suppe in die gaststätte
gehen ohne vorher eine teststation
aufzusuchen und zweitens vorsorge zu
treffen für eine zeit in der so viele
menschen gleichzeitig infiziert oder als
kontaktpersonen in quarantäne sind das
ist zu problematischen personalengpässen
kommt deshalb sollen betroffenen so
schnell wie möglich ins arbeitsleben
zurückkehren können da ging es also um
eine risikoabwägung andreas kienast
berichtet
das neue jahr beginnt wie das alte zu
ende gegangen ist mit
ministerpräsidenten die auf bildschirme
schauen mit ministerpräsidenten die sich
ganz furchtbar einig sind was zu tun ist
ab wann und wieso einig dass für die
gastronomie in deutschland zweig plus
gelten soll also zutritt für geimpfte
und genesene nur mit zusätzlichem test
ausnahme dreifach geimpfte für sie
entfällt die testpflicht das neue jahr
beginnt wie das alte zu ende gegangen
ist mit einigen ministerpräsidenten die
sofort im anschluss finden dass die
beschlüsse für irland nicht passen
deswegen sind wir skeptisch ob zweige
plus in der normalen castro jenseits von
disco jenseits von was sinnvolles ich
habe den gesundheitsminister gebeten zu
prüfen ob es aus unserer sicht wirklich
notwendig ist wir sind da sehr
zurückhaltend und skeptisch dass die
formulierung von bayern wer sind wir wo
es beigetreten weil wir genau unsere
verordnung jetzt erstmal so lassen in
den nächsten tagen wie sie ist für olaf
scholz zählen nicht die zwei skeptischen
sondern die 14 1 verstandenen länder
streit kommt nicht vor als der kanzler
die videokonferenz- schilderte große
einigkeit große handlungsfähigkeit und
noch einmal ein großes versprechen 30
millionen impfungen bis ende januar
vielleicht darf ich den satz noch sagen
wer eine möglichkeit hat sich impfen zu
lassen
sollte da nicht hingehen soll er im
rennen das ist jetzt etwas was in diesem
monat geschehen soll weil auch im neuen
jahr die korona politik nicht ohne
widersprüche ist kritisiert die cdu
scholz für ein versprechen aus dem alten
für diese aussage zur impfpflicht
deshalb finde ich wäre es richtig wenn
sie für alle gilt ab anfang februar
anfang märz inzwischen glaubt kaum noch
jemand dass dieser zeitplan zu halten
ist dieses wort muss am ende auch gelten
wir brauchen tempo und auch für tempo
und auch führung bei dieser frage ist
darf nicht das gefühl entstehen dass bei
dieser zentralen frage für die pandemie
bekämpfung taktiert wird es muss schnell
gehen und das wird es auch und davon bin
ich sehr überzeugt also ich setze mich
aktiv dafür ein dass es dazu kommt in
der sitzung hat wie schon diese woche im
kabinett hajo krömer der chef des
expertenrats vor personalmangel gewarnt
davor dass omikron die kritische
infrastruktur lahm legt auch deshalb
müssen kontaktpersonen die folge impft
sind nicht mehr in quarantäne
alle anderen können sich nach sieben
tagen frei testen die sieben tage
regelung mit eben der entsprechenden
möglichkeit der freie testung für alle
in der entsprechenden übersicht die sie
jetzt hier bekommen haben das ist eine
klare einheitliche regelung zu der wir
uns alle verständigt haben dass es bei
der komplexität der lage schon eine
große leistung die politik kämpft nicht
nur gegen korona sondern auch um ihre
einigkeit das neue jahr beginnt wie das
alte zu ende gegangen ist
und livers hamburg zugeschaltet ist uns
der erste bürgermeister der freien und
hansestadt hamburg peter tschentscher
guten abend tschentscher gut nahm slomka
in hamburg gilt ja zweig plus ab morgen
nicht nur für restaurants wie es jetzt
in diesem bundes beschlüssen steht
sondern auch für andere freizeit und
kultureinrichtungen haben sie heute
dafür plädiert dass dass es diese
umfangreichere beschränkung auch in die
beschlüsse für alle bundesländer
aufgenommen wird das gilt in hamburg ab
montag nicht nur für die gastronomie
sondern für den gesamten bereich der
freizeit der kultur des sports in
innerer weil wir sehr hohe instanzen
haben wir sind eine der ersten länder
die jetzt von der nikon welle voll
erfasst sind und deswegen müssen wir das
tun was die expertenkommission empfohlen
hat so gut es geht die infektions
dynamik bremsen und booster beides
gehört zusammen und das besagt auch der
ministerpräsidenten kommt
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschluss
von heute aber da geht es ja eben dann
für 2g plus wirklich nur um gastronomie
und selbst da findet dann zum beispiel
ihr kollege markus söder aus bayern das
sei eigentlich nicht so sinnvoll in
dieser normalen restaurant betrieb da
bräuchte man das nicht bars diskotheken
und soja die sind sowieso schon
geschlossen in bayern aber jetzt in der
normalen gaststätte um da was zu essen
das sei nicht nötig warum finden sie
doch dass es nötig ist das ist nötig
weil wir mit der omicron variante und
die werden auch in bayern und in sachsen
anhalt
werden auftreten dieser am nikon
virusvarianten da ist es sehr wichtig
dass wir in den infektions riskanten
bereichen und dazu gehört eben die
gastronomie weil man dort keine maske
trägt dass man an dieser stelle beides
macht den infektionsschutz an die erste
stelle stellen also auch testen und auf
der anderen seite damit ja auch eine
botschaft zu senden dass das boostern
jetzt wirklich wichtig ist aber auch
gewusst hatte können sich wie man
inzwischen weiß infizieren und erst
recht wenn die besteuerung schon etwas
länger her liegt und das wird dann ja
auch bei einigen den nächsten wochen so
sein nimmt auch da der infektionsschutz
ab nicht der schutz vor schweren
krankheit zwar auch über der
infektionsschutz also musste man doch
eigentlich an alle testen oder ja
natürlich es ist so dass nichts 100
prozent wirkt aber eine booster impfung
verbessert die schutzwirkung der impfung
gegenüber omikron deutlich dass es heute
vom vorsitzenden der expertenkommission
noch einmal ausdrücklich betont worden
und deswegen ist es jetzt wichtig dass
wir genug impfstoff bekommen für die
auffrischimpfung und dass alle diese
auffrischimpfung auch annehmen ja da
sagt der herr scholz heute auch man
solle zum impfen rennen aber wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe als sie ihre
eigene pressekonferenz in hamburg
abhielten gibt es da probleme weil nicht
genügend bayern tag im stoff für die
jüngeren da ist das ist genau das
problem indem wir stehen wir haben
leider keine patentrezepte können nur
mit dem impfstoff arbeiten denen es gibt
die bundesregierung hat sehr viel mehr
moderner impfstoff besorgen können das
ist sehr gut wir haben ja bis jahresende
30 millionen zusätzliche booster impfung
machen können und wollen jetzt bis ende
jahr noch einmal 30 millionen
hinbekommen und da helfen uns die
zusätzlichen moderner lieferung aber für
unter 30-jährige brauchen wir weiterhin
den biontech impfstoff für die
auffrischung und deswegen sind wir
tatsächlich in einer etwas schwierigen
lage piontek impfstoff sollte jetzt für
die jüngeren eingesetzt werden und ab 30
sollten sich alle mit der moderne mit
dem moderner impfstoff auffrischen
lassen also der hacks nach siegen gegen
die vielleicht rennen möchten rennen
danach womöglich ins ins leere was ja
nicht so schön ist sie werden ja beraten
also jedenfalls in den angeboten in
hamburg wird ausführlich beraten und da
wird gesagt dass moderne ein sehr guter
hirte unter 30 ist ja nicht zugelassen
dass nun ist zunächst ein 17-jähriger
sagte jetzt möchte ich aber auch
wirklich endlich auch geimpft werden
aber es ist hilfreich dass die über 30
jährigen jetzt den modernen stoff nehmen
wie ich zum beispiel der mit 55 jahren
natürlich gesagt hat meine auf frischen
beton kann dann mit moderner
durchgeführt werden hertha wir erwarten
ja nächste woche das da die zahlen
wahrscheinlich noch mal sehr hoch gehen
also dann reden wir vielleicht auch
nicht mehr bundesweit über 50.000 aber
noch sehr sehr sehr viel mehr oder
100.000 150.000 bis jetzt nicht an die
wand werfen wie erklären sie sich
eigentlich dass wir immer noch in seinem
daten nebel stochern dass wir in
deutschland immer diesen melde verzug
haben an feiertagen am wochenende müsste
da nicht endlich auch mal wirklich was
geändert werden andere länder dänemark
zum beispiel kriegen das ja auch hin ja
es ist natürlich bei sehr hohen
datenmengen schwierig alles zeitnah zu
machen am ende ist es ja keine computer
technik die die man alleine braucht
sondern es müssen immer wieder menschen
auf die infektionsfälle gucken gab es
schon vor infektionen ist das wirklich
eine neue infektion oder nur ein zweiter
nachweis das ist eben nicht so trivial
mit computern abzuarbeiten und deswegen
werden wir jetzt mit diesen sehr hoch
fallzahlen auch tatsächlich mit den
daten zu kämpfen haben die gute
nachricht ist aber ja dass trotz dieser
sehr vielen infektionsfälle die schweren
erkrankungen die auf den
intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen eben sehr gering sind und da sind
die daten lagen auch sehr eindeutig das
schlimme an der oregon variante ist ihre
hohe infektiosität die gute nachricht
ist im schnitt sind die erkrankung nicht
so schwer
sozusagen der hoffnungsschimmer dabei
hätte ich danke für das gespräch an
diesem späten abend freitagabend sehr
gerne
bleiben wir noch mal bei dem thema daten
tatsächlich mangelt es für ein wirklich
gutes frühwarnsystem für die kliniken
gerade auch immer noch an präzisen daten
die hospitalisierung rate etwa die einst
als neuer goldstandard gefeiert wurde
ist nach wie vor das was ihre kritiker
von anfang an attestierten ein blick in
den rückspiegel in den kliniken wünschte
man sich man wusste bei den gemeldeten
infektionen schneller welche risiken die
betroffenen in sich tragen also alter im
status vorerkrankungen dann ließe sich
präzise abschätzen wie viele der
infizierten in einer jeweiligen region
über kurz oder lang in den örtlichen
krankenhäusern landen mit dem deutschen
datenlücken hat sich lothar becker
einmal näher beschäftigt
in der uniklinik düsseldorf wie überall
in deutschland bereitet man sich wegen
omikron auf das schlimmste vor die
datenlage bei den instanzen in
deutschland könnte aber besser sein nur
wenige zusätzliche informationen zu den
neuinfizierten würden helfen wenn man
jetzt diese kombination bekommen würde
sozusagen so viele über 60 ungeimpft
vielleicht auch bestimmten medizinischen
risikoprofil wäre das natürlich eine
klarere vorhersage war das nennt sich
die gruppen die uns mit dem
allerhöchsten risiko hier die wir zu
erwarten haben und die dann auch schwere
verläufe haben wir nach den stationen
liegen aber da gibt es natürlich aspekte
des datenschutzes und auch der erfassung
die dazu führen dass wir diese daten
leider so fein aufgelöst in deutschland
nicht haben anders als zb in israel
wissen ärzte hierzulande vergleichsweise
wenig über die menschen hinter den
reinen inzidenz zahlen bis sie
eingeliefert wird das erschwert die
vorhersage des infektionsverlauf in
deutschland die instanzen sind ja keine
systematische
erfassung statistisch gesehen über die
ganze bundesrepublik sondern es kommt
darauf an wer sich zufällig testen
lassen und da muss man auch noch
gemeldet werden umgekehrt bei der post
hospitalisierung traten weiß man ja
werden krankenhaus ist aber das ist
natürlich ein bild was 10 bis 14 tage
zurückliegt und das heißt ich gucke
immer in die vergangenheit aber ich kann
nicht in die zukunft gucken mit denen
hospitalisierung fragen
professor schubert von der rwth aachen
könnte für die allgemeine
hospitalisierung rate in die zukunft
schauen wenn er systematischer zahlen
hätten also eine qualifizierte analyse
der infizierten anonym und aktuell das
wäre zum beispiel durch eine
repräsentative bevölkerungsgruppe
möglich die würde dann regelmäßig
getestet und beobachtet
wenn man solche daten zur verfügung
hätte hätte man in echtzeit sehr schnell
zuverlässige daten über den wirklichen
verlauf der infektion im anderen
krankheitsbildern gibt es solche
stichproben in deutschland schon da
hätte man ein monitoring von corona
cupid genauso aufsetzen können das wurde
nicht weiterverfolgt und das ist etwas
was uns gerade in bionicon im moment
leider auf die füße fällt ohne solche
datenerhebungen gibt es deutschlandweit
keine zeitnahen erkenntnisse zum
beispiel darüber wie lange eine
bestimmte patientengruppe durch omikron
in stationäre behandlung muss die
hochinfektiöse mutante offenbart
unübersehbar die schwächen der
etablierten strukturen im deutschen
gesundheitswesen unser system das wir in
deutschland haben ist eigentlich
weniger von den bedürfnissen des der
eigentlichen verfolgung der pandemie
getrieben sondern eher von den
institutionen die eben etabliert sind
und den verwaltungsabläufen die
etabliert sind das war am anfang der
partie liess sich aus sehr hilfreich
anders geht ging es nicht man kann sich
natürlich schon fragt noch zwei jahre
nach der pandemie es notwendig ist das
immer noch so zu machen während sich das
personal auf deutschlands kowitz
stationen aus harte wochen einstellt
fehlen weiterhin dringend notwendige
daten ohne politischen druck wird es
wohl auch künftig kein verlässliches
vorhersagemodell für die stationäre
klinikaufenthalte geben
und mit dem corona thema geht es jetzt
auch erstmal noch eine nachrichten
weiter heisst von sonntag an werden fast
40 weitere länder als hochrisiko gebiete
eingestuft eine entsprechende liste hat
das robert koch institut veröffentlicht
dazu zählt unter anderem luxemburg somit
ist von den nachbarländern deutschlands
dann nur noch österreich kein
risikogebiet
die britische regierung setzt seit heute
das militär in londoner krankenhäusern
ein dort fällt wegen der ausbreitung der
omicron variante immer mehr
klinikpersonal aus zur unterstützung
werden etwa 200 armeeangehörige in die
hauptstadt entsandt teilte das
verteidigungsministerium mit auch in
anderen landesteilen hilft das militär
den behörden bei der bewältigung der
korona pandemie
der bundesrechnungshof hält den von
finanzminister lindner vorgelegten
nachtragshaushalt für
verfassungsrechtlich zweifelhaft
in einer stellungnahme für den
haushaltsausschuss heißt es der
zusammenhang zwischen der 60 milliarden
euro zuweisung an den energie und
klimafonds und der bekämpfung der kroner
pandemie werde nicht schlüssig erläutert
lindner will 60 milliarden euro
umschichten die wegen der korona krise
2021 als kredite genehmigt warnt aber
nicht aufgenommen wurden
zum jahreswechsel hat frankreich die eu
rats präsidentschaft angetreten
frankreichs präsident makro warb zum
auftakt bei einem treffen mit dem eu
kommissionspräsidenten von der leyen in
paris für einen intensiveren austausch
mit moskau von der leyen betonte in
russland ukraine konflikt werde es keine
lösung ohne europa geben außerdem
forderten beide kasachstan zu einem ende
der gewalt auf
danach sieht es in kasachstan im moment
allerdings nicht aus im gegenteil
präsident total verteilte armee und
sicherheitskräften den schießbefehl das
heißt dass sie auch ohne jede vorwarnung
auf demonstranten schießen können
aufrufe aus dem ausland eine friedliche
lösung für die krise zu finden tat
tokarev als dummheit ab in einer tv
ansprache bedankte er sich aber bei
russlands präsident putin für die
entsendung von truppen nach
regierungsangaben wurden in den
vergangenen tagen dutzende menschen
getötet und fast 4000 sollen
festgenommen worden sein axel sturm und
christian von rechenberg mit den bildern
und informationen die uns aus dem land
erreichen
aziz ist eigentlich bankmanager heute
managt der eine kreuzung in almaty
freiwillig hauptsache irgendwas
sinnvolles tun für seine mitbürger es
schmerzt ihn sagte was er sieht was
geschehen ist aus der ferne hört man
noch immer schätze
ich glaube der staat wird nach den
ereignissen der letzten tage nicht
umhinkommen zugeständnisse zu machen den
menschen zu helfen die menschen hier
leben in armut
rund um die hauptstadt nur soltan haben
sie sechs checkpoints eingerichtet
während menschen im ganzen land
versuchen an bargeld zu kommen während
noch in der nacht der tv-sender mir
brennt und die verwüstung allgegenwärtig
ist spricht der präsident davon dass die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung
wiederhergestellt sein und behauptet
der choristen beschädigen weiterhin
staats und privateigentum und setzten
waffengewalt gegen bürger ein ich habe
den strafverfolgungsbehörden und der
armee den befehl gegeben ohne vorwarnung
das vor dazu eröffnen
die unruhen seien aus dem ausland
orchestriert wird weiter verkündet
allein die metropole an martin sei von
20.000 sogenannten banditen angegriffen
worden so wird der ruf nach den
russischen soldaten gerechtfertigt die
die gefahr abwehren sollen und deren
präsenz in kasachstan für die kameras
inszeniert wird
eigentlich ist es ein konflikt der
bürger mit ihren herrschern jetzt dabei
gibt es einen neuen aspekt intervention
von außen die regierung hat die
ausländischen soldaten eingeladen und
die ersten maschinen aus russland sind
schon in almaty gelandet eine luftbrücke
bringe soldaten rund um die uhr heißt es
seine soldaten der russischen
eingreiftruppen sind speziell
ausgebildet und haben kampferfahrung und
während die soldaten aus laden laufen
woanders die diplomatischen drähte heiß
der westen appelliert an die vernunft
wir haben eine sehr enge beziehung zu
kasachstan wir beobachten die ereignisse
mit großer sorge und ermutigen jeden
eine friedliche und konstruktive lösung
zu finden
chinas präsident ließ im fernsehen
anderes verkünden er lobte den
schießbefehl als zitat starke maßnahme
gegen eine bevölkerung die sich wehrt
die unter misswirtschaft und
repressionen leidet russland hingegen
verfolgt seine eigenen ziele
kasachstan ukraine belarus das sind
schon ganz schön viele baustellen die
russland in seinem sogenannten hinterhof
hat also in den regionen die vom kreml
als 1 fluss sphären betrachtet werden in
der ukraine ist es ein selbst gewähltes
gefährliches machtspiel die unruhen in
belarus und kasachstan hingegen dürfen
dem kreml selbst eher ungelegen kommen
hinzu kommt dann noch auf das
militärische engagement in syrien oder
die probleme mit afghanistan russland
wäre nicht die erste großmacht die
gefahr läuft sich zu übernehmen
zumal ist dadurch ja auch reichlich
konfliktstoff mit dem westen gibt
nächste woche ist erstmals seit
zweieinhalb jahren wieder ein nato
russland treffen anberaumt
im vorfeld dazu haben sich die
westlichen verbündeten heute auf einem
sondertreffen beraten eine klinik
berichtet
es sind diese satelliten aufnahmen die
die nato-partner nervös machen der
aufmarsch von russischen truppen an der
ukrainischen grenze geht unvermindert
weiter zu sehen sind militärfahrzeuge
zählte neu errichtete gebäude von
deeskalation keine spur der russische
präsident will damit druck auf den
westen ausüben kurz vor weihnachten
verschickte wladimir putin eine liste
von forderungen so genannte
sicherheitsgarantien über die putin bei
den treffen der nächsten woche reden
will so verlangt russland von der nato
die zusage dass die ukraine dem bündnis
niemals beitreten werde dass die nato
keinerlei militärische aktivitäten in
osteuropa durchführen solle und dass die
usa aller atomwaffen aus drittstaaten
abziehen müssten doch noch bevor sich
die militärs und die aussenminister der
30 nato-mitgliedsstaaten am nachmittag
zusammen schalten ist klar dass die
allianz russlands forderungen nach einem
stopp der ost-erweiterung ablehnen wird
so konnten alle länder unabhängig von
ihrer größe oder wer ihre nachbarn sind
haben das recht über diesen eigenen weg
und die eigenen verbündeten zu
entscheiden dies ist seit jahrzehnten
ein grünes prinzip der europäischen
sicherheit und russland hat sich
ebenfalls dazu bekannt
es könnte auch teil des russischen plant
sein dass sie eine liste von absolut
unerfüllbaren forderungen aufstellen um
dann zu sagen dass wir darauf nicht
eingehen um das dann als vorwand zu
nutzen für eine aggression
was also können die gespräche zwischen
russen und amerikanern und die im nato
russland rat bringen wenigstens reden
heißt die devise sich gegenseitig
informieren übungen ankündigen die nato
will vor dem treffen geschlossenheit
demonstrieren und doch gibt es
mindestens zwei lager die einen team
dialog mit deutschland und frankreich
als hauptvertreter es geht um
traditionelle russland freundlichkeit um
wirtschaftsinteressen und den glauben
dass dialog nie falsch sein
frankreich wird weiter mit russland
reden ich hatte zwei lange telefonate
mit präsident putin in den letzten
wochen und ich werde in den nächsten
tagen wieder mit ihm reden die anderen
team härte walten und osteuropäer hier
bei einer nato übung sind traditionell
russland feindlich sie fürchten
zugeständnisse der westeuropäer an putin
über ihre köpfe hinweg und wünschen sich
nicht dialog sondern abschreckung
angesichts des zunehmend aggressiven
verhaltens von russland gegenüber der
ukraine glaube ich dass es im interesse
der nato liegt die truppenpräsenz im
baltikum und in polen zu verstärken
ein wunder ist also nicht zu erwarten
einen durchbruch auch nicht
möglicherweise wäre es schon ein erfolg
wenn die nato mit einer stimme spreche
und russland sich die kritik des westens
wenigstens anhört und
jetzt nochmal heinz mit wirtschaft und
heute auch noch einmal mit dem thema
inflation
denn nachdem es gestern neue zahlen für
deutschland gab kamen heute daten zur
teuerung im euroraum insgesamt
domenicalis meister wie sieht es da aus
ja mit 5 prozent ist die inflation in
der eurozone im dezember auf ein neues
rekordhoch gestiegen der höchste wert
seit einführung des euro die stärkste
preissteigerung wurde in den baltischen
ländern gemessen in estland war die
inflation mit zwölf prozent am höchsten
im mittelfeld die niederlande mit 6,4
den niedrigsten wert meldet und malta
mit 2,6 prozent die rufe werden lauter
nach einer zinserhöhung der ezb
andererseits könnten höhere zinsen das
wirtschaftswachstums bremsen
herausforderung für den neuen
präsidenten der bundesbank joachim nagel
bekam heute vom bundespräsidenten seine
ernennungsurkunde
nagl übernimmt die führung der
bundesbank in unruhigen zeiten denn als
vertreter deutschlands im ezb rat ist er
verantwortlich für die geldpolitik der
eurozone spannend wird nun ob nagel wie
sein vorgänger weidmann auf eine
kurskorrektur drängt euphorie herrscht
zum wochenschluss an der börse nicht der
dax verlor heute
0,655 cent
1947 punkte für die erste handelswoche
des jahres ergibt sich aber immerhin ein
leichtes plus von 0,4 prozent
dominik leßmann ist doch vielen dank
die fußball bundesliga ist in der
rückrunde gestartet tabellen
spitzenreiter bayern münchen hat 1 zu 2
gegen borussia mönchengladbach verloren
die deutsche handball nationalmannschaft
hat ihr vorletztes testspiel vor der em
gewonnen 30 zu 26 hieß es am ende gegen
die schweiz für die neu formierte
mannschaft von bundestrainer kießler
song gleich neun debütanten reisen mit
zur em in ungarn und der slowakei die
nächste woche beginnt letzter
testspielgegner am sonntag ist
olympiasieger frankreich
er verwirklichte wirklich den
amerikanischen traum vom tellerwäscher
zum hollywood-star
aber erlebte auch die amerikanischen
albträume den rassismus und die
benachteiligung der schwarzen auch als
schauspieler in der traumfabrik
sind eine partie schaffte dann aber was
kein schwarzer vor ihm schaffte mit
einem oscar für die beste männliche
hauptrolle auf der bühne zu stehen im
alter von 94 jahren ist er jetzt
gestorben anfang kurschilgen erinnert an
diesen weltstar und seinem lebensweg
[Musik]
zugangscodes er war einer der ganz
großen charakterdarsteller in hollywood
[Musik]
ich brauche eine abspielung des einsatz
berichtet november
ich habe es eigentlich
sydney portier als fbi-agentin versucht
ein attentat auf die first lady zu
verhindern ich bin ein richtiger held
dank ihnen der agent der die first lady
gerettet hat
ich könnte für den rest meines lebens
scheiße bauen und wäre trotzdem
unantastbar
partie dessen karriere am broadway
begann glänzte 1963 in lilien auf dem
felde
ein film der sich behutsam und humorvoll
mit rassismus in den usa
auseinandersetzt
dafür wurde er mit einem oscar
ausgezeichnet er war der erste schwarze
schauspieler der einen oscar als bester
hauptdarsteller gewann
[Musik]
auch im echten leben setzte er sich ein
für die gleichberechtigung von afro
amerikaner 1963 porti an vorderster
front bei protesten der
bürgerrechtsbewegung in washington der
us-amerikaner war auch staatsbürger der
bahamas 1997 wurde ihm eine besondere
ehre zuteil er wurde zum botschafter der
bahamas in japan berufen
[Musik]
meine aufgabe als botschafter
konkurriert nicht mit meinem beruf als
schauspieler beides passt gut zusammen
ich bin nicht gezwungen eine der beiden
aufgaben zu bevorzugen
es gibt zeiten da mache ich filme als
schauspieler oder regisseur aber ich
werde immer meiner verantwortung als
botschafter nach kommen
für sein engagement wurde er 2009 auch
von barack obama ausgezeichnet mit der
freiheitsmedaille des präsidenten
sydney partie wird in erinnerung bleiben
als engagierter bürgerrechtler und als
großartiger charakter darsteller
so das war für uns und jetzt gleich geht
es weiter mit der doku der schatz des
priamos wem gehört das gold von troja
entdeckt hatte es ja der vor 200 jahren
geborene heinrich schliemann und dessen
umstrittenes erbe in diesem
jubiläumsjahr vielfach erinnert wird und
uns beide gibt es dann morgen wieder um
22 uhr 45
[Musik]
guten abend kaum ist das eine schnee und
regen band hier nach osten abgezogen
kommt schon gleich ein neues schneetief
er an dass überquert uns heute nacht und
morgen über tag dann wird es
vorübergehend ein bisschen freundlicher
aber das dauert nicht lange denn dann
kommt hier von westen schon gleich das
nächste wettersystem heran und bringt
von westen wieder schnee und regen heute
nacht also fällt erstmal noch schnee und
regen hier im osten dann kommt das
kleine tieferen das bringt vielleicht
auch mal gewitter mit und es wird
gefährlich glatt auf den straßen nicht
nur in den mittelgebirgen können zwei
bis zehn zentimeter neuschnee fallen und
die bleiben in jedem fall auch liegen
denn die temperaturen sinken auf plus 1
bis minus 7 grad mittags dann bilder
dann geht es dem schnee im flachland
auch wieder an den kragen die
höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen minus
ein und plus 6 grad morgen vormittag
schneit es noch hier entlang der alpen
auch richtung thüringen dann wird erst
mal ganz freundlich das ändert sich aber
schon am nachmittag wenn mit einem
stürmischen südwind von westen wieder
neue schnee und regen wolken heran
kommen am sonntag wird es dann sehr
gründlich es gibt schnee und regenfälle
auch mal graupel gewitter und hier im
thüringer wald und im erzgebirge können
bis zu 20 zentimeter neuschnee fallen
die sonne sehen wir kaum mal wenn dann
wohl allenfalls an der ostseeküste das
gute an dem wochenende ist irgendwann
ist es vorbei dann kommt die neue woche
und die bringt uns deutlich ruhigeres
winterwetter guten abend